so one thing I learned from the pickup  event this was so fun I had a great time  I was I felt like a dude because I was  like get her get her go get it  no it was free because I I had like no I  mean I had the guy on my channel so I  had a boyfriend then so I had the guy on  my channel I just had to make good  content like a girl going to a pickup  event I had um it wasn't worth it I had  to blur so many faces it took too long  too long but but  um I was like they had to approach so  many girls just to get like laid  basically and this was even the  instructors who were like in my opinion  like they're very very good looking so I  was like I could like I don't know some  of them had I would say yeah it's about  your boyfriend  um no no I didn't no I didn't do it like  you could have asked any of them I  didn't like entered why would I want to  sleep with a guy that just slept with  three girls in three days